with business in my opinion ego is the
enemy I just realized that it was the
root of all the unhappiness that I had
and like everything that I have was in
comparison to other people with for no
reason
I think the biggest thing that changes
is time Horizon and I think the single
greatest differentiator between the poor
and the middle class middle class and
rich rich and the truly wealthy is how
they see time and if you think about
money as simply a condensed unit of time
right that's all money is like you can
trade time for money so like it is
they're almost equivalent units and the
people who know how to master their time
the most mean that they know how to
master their money the most so the
original question of like how do wealthy
people come wealthy is because they
Master their time I think it's fear
mostly I know that's not a skill but I
think it's a character trait and so
people are afraid of not getting
validated or they're afraid of judgment
that they perceive from other people
that exist or don't exist in their lives
and so for whatever reason they have
this second voice that criticizes
everything they do that in reality isn't
even there but it's constantly present
it's like the antithesis of whatever the
god figure is but just the negative
voice and so I think that's the thing
that stops most people from doing the
stuff they know they need to do because
if you think about like whether it's
want to get in shape or I want to have a
better marriage or I want to make more
money most people on some level at a
basic level they know what to do and my
proof point of like even making money
right most of us have had a bill that
came up that was unexpected a tax bill a
car breaks down a health thing whatever
it is and we find a way and so when it's
for someone else
people are will use the actual
resourcefulness that they have to make
the money but for whatever reason they
won't use that same resourcefulness to
make it for themselves and so I think
that most people know if they want to
work out uh start to get in shape or to
lose weight whatever they know they need
to eat fewer donuts and move more in
general
but they don't right because they're
afraid of getting started or they don't
have the discipline to keep going which
is they can't make the short-term
sacrifice for the long-term achievement
so big picture it's like there's usually
some fear that's preventing from doing
it and then how it looks from a
behavioral standpoint is they do not
make the short-term sacrifice of
discomfort for the long-term achievement
independent of whatever path they're
talking about you've got this whole
Space right and you look at like if
you're like I want to be a business
influencer right well it's like we look
at the guys who are actually the top of
the business game and virtually everyone
have killed it in business and most of
them even Gary had gone to 60 million a
year before he made his first content
and so I think the issue is that people
look at that and say I should make
content like them when you don't have
you can't answer the underlying question
which is why should I listen to you
which is always in the back of every
audience's mind in my opinion at least
that's what I think like when someone's
like a relationship expert and I find
out they've been divorced three times
I'm like you know maybe not right I mean
and as terrible as it is they might be
giving amazing advice but it doesn't
pass the first filter which is if I'm
going to take military strategy from
someone I'd rather have a general that
has a winning record Napoleon said I'd
rather have lucky generals
so even if he had two that were even
you'd rather have the lucky one and so
to the same degree I think people use
that filter because it actually takes
less effort to learn from someone that
you trust and so it's like if you've got
the the basement teacher that's selling
it a dollar cost average of the s p and
you've got Warren Buffett who's telling
people to dollar cost average in the s p
they don't want to listen to the teacher
even if the teacher is better
objectively from a constant standpoint
because they just don't know if they
should trust them so you have to have
two filters I'm hearing the thing should
I trust the thing with Warren you can
just plug into whatever he's saying just
take it as truth which takes less effort
and I think a lot of people would get
much bigger better audiences and
actually make more money from the
content that they're making because
everyone else is like why should I
listen to you I think it's a frame shift
that at least has been very valuable for
me to understand which is that whatever
I want there is a cost to getting it and
so the the first time I heard this was
actually a somebody who's using it to
close an event and they were saying and
they wrote they wrote a million dollars
on the board
and they asked somebody in the audience
how much they make and they I think they
answered fifty thousand dollars and he
said and then you put fifty thousand
dollars underneath a million bucks and
he drew a line and they put 950 000. he
said it is costing you 950 000 every
year to not know how to make a million
dollars and that like he didn't call it
ignorance tax I've called it that since
then but like you can put whatever
number you want it cost me a billion
dollars a year not to know how to make a
billion dollars a year in income right
that idea for me has been fundamental to
like I will pay for whatever shortcut
possible there is value in someone
helping you
get somewhere faster and making sure
that that person has helped people like
you get to where you want to go is a
great first litmus has to look through
that big breakthrough that I had for me
was when I stopped focusing on and this
is going to sound backwards but when I
started my gyms I was all about building
the business and when I built the
biggest companies that I've had and now
recently sold and now we have our
portfolio it was about how do we make
the most money
and I know that sounds completely
backwards but the only way that you can
make the most money is to provide an
exceptional valued service and charge a
ton of money for it and because I
optimized around making money I I
started going for low Capital expense
businesses because I had lost everything
after that five-year stint and so I was
like never again am I going to reinvest
every dollar from the business back into
the business because
I've lost it before so when I started
the the next business and every business
I've had thereafter like we take
dividends every month and the thing is
and this was a fallacy I had because
people always talk about like
reinvesting in their business but I
realized that that just meant that they
weren't making profit and so the vast
majority of businesses even the software
world is somewhat shifting in this but
they want to see profit and then even
better is if you have net free cash flow
which is just a fancy word for the
amount of money that you can take out
every month after making Necessary
investments in the business and so I
wanted to have businesses that pumped
cash flow because I lost it all before
if I were just to use history as a as a
as a guide business has only gotten
easier to get into it's gotten more
competitive and easier to get into and
so I think that what happens is just the
arena gets bigger so you got more
Gladiators so it's more competitive but
more people can walk in and so I think
but it but for the world in general
the more people you have fighting to
make amazing products and services the
better it is for society but the
downstream effect of that is that in a
capitalist system it is a winner take
all
for most for for many not all but for
many businesses and just by the nature
of it that does create social
disarray and it's just but the thing is
it's like it's still the best system
that we have we don't have a perfect
system because the other systems remove
incentive and Humanity doesn't buy
incentive yeah even the survivorship
bias like every MLM in the world exists
off the fact that there's that one guy
who makes 500 000 a month selling shake
mix and the other five million Jake mix
producers are like someday yeah and it's
just survivorship bias right but that's
why the whole capitalist machine works
so I think they're like figuring out
some sort of a you know
creative way
if somebody is starting from scratch
what are the traits skill sets that they
should be cultivating in order to up the
odds of their success
they should focus on one thing in
general rather than lots of different
things that you're not sure about
because if you're starting out
everything looks like an opportunity so
the correct answer is all of them are
opportunities but all of them won't work
unless you pick one right so you have to
say no to all the other Mistresses so
boom you pick one and then from there I
always say six figures is sell something
to someone that's it and if you want
more detail sell something to someone so
it's one Avatar one product one channel
so you don't have to figure out how do I
create 20 pieces of content across it's
like
just pick one channel one media Source
whether it's Facebook Instagram YouTube
you know whatever Twitter consistently
start going on that whether that's cold
outbound whether that's content whether
it's running paid ads whether it's
Affiliates Word of Mouth whatever it is
and start reaching out to people there
to start selling your stuff so I use
something that I call the rule 100 which
is 100 primary actions whether that's
100 minutes of of content creation per
day 100 reach outs per day uh 100 of AD
spend per day uh like you have to pick
one of them but 100 per day and you do
that for 100 days and I promise you'll
have you'll be making six figures if you
do that vast majority of people are
pitching all the time are natural
promoters not product people Naval had
this quote that I really like he said
you're only selling because you don't
know how to Market and you only Market
because you don't know how to build a
product because like the best products
market and sell themself now obviously
if you're Steve Jobs or Elon Musk it's
like you build amazing products and then
you back them with unbelievable
marketing and then you have an army of
sales people that that you know are
selling for you so it's like then you
have them all then you have you know a
trillion dollars yeah yeah yeah but like
just being exceptional any of those will
make you money but you get the
multiplicative you know compounding
effect if you're good at two or three of
them